I saw that last tour today so obviously
we're in London is the flooring say what
would be your dream day off by now I
really like Henley handling on James I
lived up there for a little bit when I
was shooting fury so I like to I like
that area I probably go up there and
area lunch any English pulpit without
your fancy I can't remember the names
hey may I hang this up would you like a
smoke and that's what we got coefficient
chips oh yeah we can't not be any ones
and have different extra passenger at
eight is a huge like franchise when
you're nervous on your first day of like
blocking up on set sure a little bit
yeah
I think you know it was such a big cast
is such a such a great task but you know
they were really great about welcoming
me with open arms
so it f day 100 okay everyone's so cool
this is going to be really fun
there's so many guys are not films
there's play a few bromances involved I
was always you know a big fan of
Ludacris growing up and you know Tyrese
and and then and everybody from the
franchise so I mean I think I brought
out with a lot of them are nice and and
so there's a lot of Brits in this movie
and Helen Mirren nastily ammonia
oxidation state on what's the biggest
difference between working with Brits
and Americans on a film and I don't
really notice
Jason's great Natalie he's incredible
I didn't get to work with Helen but I
hear she's great
natalie is a big sweetheart she's a
quiet little you know tea-drinking
sweetheart you just just wanted oh
they're hugging give her a big hug every
day would you rather go for a cup of tea
I know you haven't met Helen Mirren on
the set but would you want to go for a
cup of tea around with friends house or
around Helen Mirren
hmm I forgot it but probably say the
Queen I mean yeah you can't pop it by
inviting in it I don't even know where
that is like in comparison to where we
are right now they need an island invest
in a big red versus a night going to
decide what ministers next time see you
consumer goods
British accent sport of tea oh my god
and it's caesium and then in cabby
accent oh no but that one here yours
come on oh I'm loving that accent quite
terrible but no I'm not even gonna lie
no no a little bit and I hide I'm really
hot and it if I wasn't sign this car
right now it would be your dream car
component you obviously well no not my
object I'm not a man I'm not gonna lie
and I might just say that clip no for me
and but who else would be your dream was
budget my buds from high school and you
know buds and I've been friends with for
20 years
are you good at driving yeah I Drive it
to Grandma yeah when I was not inspected
are you happy in custom serious and died
my special I must not know they don't
really seem to go hand in hand
no I do I don't like a grandma look so
that's my buddies tell me this violent
women so you play a bookie in Fast and
Furious I do but in real life do you
abide by the rules a bit of a rule
breaker people rule burger oh you always
have it drive like a grandma I love that
have you ever been to traffic all
traffic Scott one of those oh and in
trouble now in range of off
maybe years ago I don't remember was for
a speeding yeah speeding I used to tell
you to drive faster okay he's family I
just broke up you know a few tickets and
here's and I really like paying them
then you know they double or triple and
then you have to get to figure it out
but ultimately I think I to go to travel
school one time Northy and then did your
dad teach you to drive my dad did to
Schmeer on today when you look at people
I I learned in an old Ford pickup truck
they used to call it throw down the tree
of the late shift on an old old pickup
truck and that's what I that's what I
learned on oh okay and then what it's
like the best of Viator does ever given
you just growing up sit as a young lad
shut up and listen oh I mean that's
always there I feel kid supervisor to
abide by isn't it really
you've had some parking ticket how do
you tweaked or park1 now for I think the
Hollywood stardom lasted maybe it as a
way of getting out of a parking ticket
now yeah I still get parking tickets you
don't you know you know my heart oh baby
bloom aye
oh no I took a parking ticket all the
time it's a problem with God into me
mate Chinese Ron is like my girl
question certified a little awesome in
its own it is calling relicensing she's
totally cool she searches awesome she's
totally down there great and you know
what a great actress
yeah she's been in she's ready yes
twitcam info yeah yeah okay so what's on
your vote trip playlist
there's probably some George Strait in
there call Chris Stapleton a little
t-swift blues brothers are in there a
traffic case yeah in seventies and funk
can you things I call with everything
you know or don't you must know just
like you ain't gonna do I mean sorry
jabya sorry I can't engage I was like a
good job is no need to pay right up we
try to be constantly fast for constant
if you think about it
some Express okay that's a great outside
lastly if you drive faster than this guy
right here
yes yeah okay having like a like my
great-grandma yeah I'm I'm my grandma
you're my great-grandma